[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS CAPLICE: Supply chain management
is the backbone of the global economy.
Regardless of your
role within a firm you
will interface with the supply chain.
Supply chains span time zones,
continents, cultures, and companies.
Everything that you touch and use
came through some supply chain.
The ability to manage these
far-flung and complex networks
now are seen as crucial to the
success or failure of a firm.
My name is Chris Caplice and I'm
the Executive Director of the Center
for Transportation and
Logistics here at MIT.
I'll be your instructor
for the course CTL.SC1x.
Supply Chain and Logistics Fundamentals.
This is the first of three courses
that we will offer in the XSeries
for supply chain management.
So what is logistics and
supply chain management?
Basically, it's the art and
science of getting products
from where they were made to where
you the consumer want them to be.
Firms have become more global in terms
of where they source materials, where
they manufacture those products and
where they sell their finished goods.
And the need for professionals
who can design, manage and operate
these complex global supply
chains continues to grow.
So what will you learn
if you take this course?
Basically, you'll master the
fundamental logistical concept
and build the intuition needed to
successfully manage a supply chain.
And, specifically, we'll
focus on three core areas.
First, we'll explore
forecasting and demand planning.
This is where all supply chains start.
You'll learn the strengths
and the weaknesses
of using different forecasting
methods and understand
when and how to use each of them.
Second, we'll dive into
inventory management.
And in this phase
you'll learn how to make
sure your products are in stock,
on the shelf and readily available
for someone to purchase.
You'll learn how to
determine how much and where
to keep your products in order to make
the correct trade-off between cost
and service.
Finally, we'll cover
freight transportation.
We'll show how raw materials, work
in progress and finished goods
all move across the globe.
You'll learn how to decide what mode
you're products should travel on.
You'll learn how to calculate the
best way to distribute products
through various channels to include
large mega-retailers, smaller
neighborhood stores or
even to individual homes.
I love teaching this course because the
concepts and techniques are universal.
The approaches and trade-offs
that a global manufacturing
firm uses in its supply
chain also apply to how
you decide to buy your groceries.
Supply chain management is
a fascinating, exciting,
and growing discipline.
I hope that you will decide
to join us and take the course
c Supply Chain and
Logistics Fundamentals.